for the last couple of days since the
NFC Championship game about what you
think the NFL should do or what rules
should be changed with the replay system
in order to make sure what we saw at the
end of the a NFC champion game does not
happen again and we figured you know
what let's get somebody from the
competition committee itself on the
phone line and we are thrilled to have
the Dallas Cowboys EBP Co o director of
player personnel Steven Jones here on
the program how are you Steven
hey rich man I'm doing great hope you're
having a good week and we're down here
at the Senior Bowl having to move on
since we're out of the tournament now
and looking to make ourselves better
okay well maybe we can revisit that in a
second I do want to hit on the subject
du jour about the end of the NFC
Championship game and what do you think
the the general sense of things is from
the management level the ownership level
in the competition committee level that
you represent on one Stephen absolutely
well I think you know when I first doing
the committee risks the one thing we
learned right away is you don't make
major decisions and have knee-jerk
opinions and then the other term I
learned early and often are the
unintended consequences I think you know
in general obviously you look at the
call obviously that that's in question
and certainly you know it's a tough one
it's a tough one you know obviously for
the Saints they certainly play that
forward and see where they are in the
Super Bowl right now and understand that
but at the same time if you get into you
know the far-reaching consequences of
that which are you know how do you
insert pass interference and any type of
replay you know it's a very judgmental
call at the end of the day and although
that one two most appeared obvious
there's a lot of pass interference call
because of the contact we have in our
game all the hand fighting that goes on
down the field you know it's a very
judgmental call that's not always clear
and obvious you know it can certainly be
that it could certainly be a case made
that there's no PR calls and aren't pass
interference that you know happy
people think they are and how people
think they aren't but you know obviously
we'll take a look as we do everything
and it deserves a long look and a lot of
provocative conversations will be had on
you know how you know how to move
forward with something like that I think
it was all a call that we you know hate
hate that was messed at the same time no
one has more respect for our officials
than myself I mean they there's a you
know a lot of pressure put on them
there's 22 players out on that field
there's a lot of space you know there's
a lot of you know contact that goes on
in our game which is expected and you
know they have tough duties so I have
nothing but the utmost respect for them
it's our job you know as a league as a
competition committee to continue to
improve and make our game better for our
fans in terms of officiating and it's
our job to put them in better places and
I don't have the answer to that on my
fingertips as we sit here today I
certainly look forward to sitting with
them you know with my fellow competition
committee members our NFL staff and
looking for ways to improve our football
game yeah I'm sure of Shan Peyton you
know obviously he's on the committee
he'll be in the room have you had any
conversations with him at all yet Steven
I have not I have not I have let him
certainly let this all kind of emotion
or work its way as we all have in all
these games and then we were involved in
a you know we've been involved in games
like that work you know officiating can
be contested and certainly it's an
emotional roller coaster that you go
through I think anybody who's been
involved in the NFL and been involved in
games probably at one time or another
have had you know calls that work your
way and you have calls that work against
you but certainly when it's done you
know at a you know in these playoff
games work you know it's it's eluded you
go home then there's a lot more emotion
involved but you know shines very very
smart coach he adds a lot to the
committee I know they'll have a lot of
great ideas as well the other members as
well as will our staff
well I've got a good idea Stephen Jones
if you don't mind me forwarding it to
you I'm absolutely never been shy not
always open to ideas and I always opened
up for ways to get better so I'd love to
hear yours because I'd love to look I
understand the sensitivity on the front
of the difficulty of the job
I mean fans if they're ever fortunate
enough to get close to the field just
that the guys are so big they're so fast
it's remarkable that that the calls are
right as much as they are okay so I
understand that and I understand the
crucible of the of the game like there
was at the end of the NFC champion game
it's pressurized but having replay as a
safety net to me might take some of the
pressure off and certainly help in a
situation like this one which way I
think we can all agree we don't want to
see any more and I also understand the
sensitivity of having judgment calls
folded in to replay that said making
everything reviewable when I say
everything anything's reveal anything
but you don't you don't expand the
number of challenges available to the
coaches at all so you don't extend the
game you do however maybe get more
challenges made which might extend the
game but it's not appreciably extended
and in the last two minutes
anything is reviewable by the booth and
New York City but it has to be you would
come up with some language clear use the
words yourself or earlier in this
instant into this interview clear and
obvious any clear and obvious penalty
can be reviewed in the last two minutes
what do you think well I just think it's
something we should discuss I'm sure
we'll be discussed we certainly heard
this before I think clear and obvious is
the key and how do you define clear and
obvious and you know because there's a
lot of a lot of calls that people think
are clear and obvious depending on which
side of it right which team you're
rooting for that Saints and they'd be
clear and obvious to Aram saying they
not a Cowboys fan they'd be clear and
obvious to an Eagles fan may not and you
know you just get in that when you get
into judgment calls that's what you get
into and
I think if you hear smart people on
broadcast whether it's a Troy Aikman or
a Joe Buck whether it's Tony Romo and
Jim Nantz they're very knowledgeable
about our game and when they're having
their conversations with with the
officials in the booth there's
differences of opinion there by very
smart people as to what the reason you
know when there is replay how it should
go
when there is a call how it should go so
it's a you know it's a it's certainly
something that's very difficult to get
your hands around once you move past you
know once you get into the judgment
calls like pass interference holding
things of that nature so you know you
know all these are very valid points
they're good points they're all points
that we will I'm sure have you know a
lot of discussion as there's as it
should be and we all want the game to be
better we all want it to be better for
our fans we all want to get it right we
all want to put our officials in the
very best possible position to get it
right and at the same time we want to
have great flow to our ball games and
you know you can't at the end of the day
you have to live with we've been living
with it in sports for forever that
there's going to be missed calls at
times and so those were all things that
we have to measure and we'll certainly
be doing that in a big way in in this
offseason it's certainly you know
whenever you have a season you you have
a lot of things that a lot of questions
that are raised that the competition
committee has to address certainly will
we'll have our hands full again that's
offseason so we'll call it the Eisen
rule that'll be on the agenda is what
you're saying certainly we'll take a
look at it I can assure you that that
will come up and that has before it's
certainly one that's you know you put a
lot of thought into and I'm not saying
I've heard it before
okay I think something that will
obviously discuss yeah I guess it's just
just closing a loophole that look as you
point out loophole calling it that would
be calling it that for the last century
or plus in sports about officia
officials or humans and making calls and
then worn on calls I are
totally get it but just closing up
whatever possibly can happen that the
NFC Championship game unfortunately
drove through like a Mack truck in front
of a huge American viewing public
just closing that up that's that's all
I'm I think many fans are looking at
right now seven I think the challenge
riches just are you doing that every
play without a pic was that an offensive
holding clear and obvious was that clear
and obvious base mass was that a clear
and obvious head to the head and then
you're into the debate in New York you
know as to you know is it clear and
obvious and it's every play I mean you
go back and looked at the final two
minutes of the KC New England game
there's pick plays there's pass
interference there's face masks there
sits to the head or non heads to the
head I mean you get into you may not
ever make it through the final two
minutes and and that's without getting
into when TV goes to work on this you
know what was that guy holding was the
defensive guy holding was that I mean as
you know there's a case to be made that
there's some form of a penalty on every
play you know these guys are coached to
be physical and coach to push the limits
and we're talking about very skilled
guys who are big and fast and you know
it's you know you really question if
that's what we really want couple more
minutes left with Stephen Jones here
Cowboys executive vice president I'm
gonna front load this in case let's say
and you and I've had a conversation off
air about this so I figured I'd bring it
up now in Super Bowl 53 a member of the
Rams or the Patriots so the Patriots
don't usually do this because Belichick
coaches against it but remember the Rams
the Patriots reaches for the pylon with
a ball and it goes through the end zone
and the ball goes to the defense
what is the appetite of the competition
committee to change this rule Stephen
Jones it's been gone in the past it has
been gone over extensively and I think
you know at the end of the day it's
strict liability on that runner to
secure it and he fumbles before he gets
it across the goal line and that was his
to say
and to be careless with the ball or take
a chance to score a touchdown we're and
he has to make that decision so we've
made the decision not to change the rule
in the past but certainly you know it
comes up and as far as I can remember it
comes up almost every year that we
certainly look at three or four plays on
that because usually it happens a couple
of times a year and we make sure that
that's the stance that while that we
want to keep and why why why is it well
I'd said ultimate opinion becomes it's
you know strict liability on the runner
to make that it happened I stare at car
went for the touchdown and he reached
for it and he takes a chance at that
point that he's going to fumble that
ball and it's going to go through the
end zone and if he secures the bald and
he has to line up the next play you'll
end up probably your yard short no it's
their job to get the ball in on the next
play okay you know where I stand on it
by the way yes what's great about our
game what's great about our fans is
everyone certainly has where it has
opinions and by the way as you well know
there's a lot of differing opinions in
the room it's a lot of times it's never
a lot of times it's not unanimous and
you certainly have people on both sides
of the equation if you will or the
equation you know some wanted some don't
want something in terms of a specific
rule so the good news is it's a well
thought out as you know what the
competition committee makeup is it's
made up of coaches GM's owners etc in
terms of you know looking at what's in
the best interest of our game and
certainly we understand that people
don't always agree the fans don't always
agree owners within the rest don't agree
with the committee and within the
committee you have certainly
disagreements so it's a very thick okay
Steven just a couple quick hitters on
the cowboys if you don't mind before
letting you go when do you think you
might have an announcement on the
offensive coordinator for your team you
know I think as we move forward you know
we're obviously at this point pretty
comfortable
with what we have internally but we have
our coaches as it turns out or down at
the Pro Bowl coaching the Pro Bowl so
we're gonna have some meetings some this
week down there we're gonna move from
the Senior Bowl to the Pro Bowl and then
we'll obviously all convene back next
week but I would think about by the by
next week we'll be making a final
decision on that okay and I don't know
if you were aware of what Cole Beasley
was tweeting out yesterday about
management deciding who gets the
football in an offensive scheme Stephen
I would hope that's just his frustration
but certainly not at all the case I mean
we don't get involved in that we do you
no longer think ever did decide to tell
you we're gonna you know pay players a
lot of money here we're gonna trade the
players and give up big picks as we
certainly hope that they would be
involved you know if we're gonna do
things like that there's a reason we're
doing it that they're gonna be involved
but we would never dictate where balls
go or things of that nature in terms of
the game plan and getting involved with
our coaching staff does - you're ready
to play ball game and lastly and
certainly I quote and certainly of all
people Cole's always involved in getting
balls and getting catches and you know
he's been a just an integral part of
what we're about and I certainly made a
lot of big catches and key catches and
and games that we've won and had success
with and lastly Jack and Zeke are they
up for renegotiating right now or you
know we certainly those are all guys
that we want to be on our team a long
term and we'll be working with a handful
of really top in players that we have on
our team this year I think it's well
documented between the Marcus Lawrence
between Amari Cooper between Byron Jones
and back in Zeke but all those players
are players that we want to be wearing a
cowboy uniform for years to come so
they'll certainly be a methodical
process that we'll work through with
them and their agents and certainly some
timing involved with all the above but
we intend to keep
those guys in terms of their long-term
future with the Cowboys well Stephen we
had Jaylon Smith on on NFL gameday
morning championship Sunday what a great
human being that that guy is I mean you
you struck it with him and so many other
guys at you and you and the staff and
your dad have drafted there and the
Cooper trade for the first-round pick
you got a lot of heat for the
first-round pick and he just absolutely
was dynamite so Congrats on all those
moves panning out and getting the NFC
East championship this year for sure
well thank you we won't take that next
step and you know be talking hopefully
won't be playing football in the future
this time of year as well
we've got a good young team and we're
certainly optimistic but we have to get
better and hopefully improve on what we
did last year but they've been on the
key thanks for the call Stephen really
appreciate it at Stephen Jones Cowboys
executive vice president from the Senior
Bowl which you can by the way watch on
NFL Network's Saturday right here on the
Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience